[Musik]
den letzten tagen ja man muss sagen die
die hier ihre kinder auf dem mit dabei
wenn wir uns jetzt angucken was die
relativ erfolgreich gewesen hier wurden
haben die wirklich bis vor kurzem im
menschen darum tragen was die soldaten
auch heute wollen wir uns die
vier kleinere orte erobert wir zeigen
tragen sind das auch alles verschiedene
bunker gesessen haben sagt ihr geht ja
militärische lage in der ukraine
angucken wollen uns putins krieg ansehen
panzerabwehrwaffen eine rpg 22 sehen wir
ziel lagen ihr geht jetzt in einer reihe
dass mal einmal südlich der stadt traf
immer nur einen schritt zwischen euch
wie er dann vonstatten geht und wir
hier der nächste hat hier eine britische
und einmal südlich von easy um auch eine
und wir zeigen euch wo es lang geht also
beginnen mit ganz aktuellen bildern aus
sehr wichtige stadt hier dringend
diese menschen werden behandelt wirklich
nvidia mit sich trägt und hier sehen wir
russland langsam unter schweren
nikolajew ganz kurz zur einordnung
wie ja wie viel muss man sagen von der
eine apg 7 das heißt auch hier versuchen
verlusten aber doch eben vor und wie sie
russischen armee da sieht man kein
nicolai eine der städte hier im süden
die ukraine ähnlich wie es vor kiew sehr
mitleid kann kein mitgefühl oder
das machen und welche unhcr us-band
der ukraine auch sozusagen ganz in der
ähnliches wir sehen hier dieses
gut funktioniert hat mit kleinen mobilen
taktiken sie da anwenden gucken uns
wohnviertel werden herausgebracht links
nähe der front etwa 20 30 kilometer von
einmal kurz an
teams die ihm alle möglichen
nämlich ein russischer kampfhubschrauber
panzerabwehrwaffen haben die russen den
ihr entfernt
und rechts stehen die russischen
dort wo eigentlich gerade keine mega
soldaten passen auf dass dort ja dass
aufzulauern die zu finden die panzer in
der hier gefilmt wurde der ein angriff
offensive der russen vorangeht aber dort
den wäldern und dann zu zerstören
dort sozusagen kein widerstand entsteht
vollzieht und dieser angriff ist ja aus
inwiefern das in zukunft hoffentlich
wo und das werden wir gleich sehen auch
bei diesen menschen aufnahmen aus der
weiter der russische terror gegen die
militärischer sicht extrem seltsam und
nähe von aosta menschen man sieht dass
besser funktioniert als in den letzten
zivilbevölkerung vorangebracht wird
tagen wo russland schon etwas
die sind absolut mitgenommen also wir
so was hat man auch sonst nicht gesehen
bilder von gestern abend die die
vorangekommen ist wird sich dann noch
wir sehen hier relativ tief liegt dieser
hubschrauber fliegt über die wiesen und
haben herrn landrut zurück auch gesehen
innenstadt zeigen von nicolai wir sehen
zeigen
gleich wird er feuer und
dass am ende einige ihrer verwandten auf
hier immer wieder diese blitze da sehen
wir in der mitte eine kirche wenn man
dieses feuer geht normalerweise ja auf
der schulter tragen ja das ist wirklich
mal genau hinsieht und wir sehen die für
wie ich finde es schwer zu ertragende
hochhäuser links und rechts und wir
ein ziel normalerweise ist ein ein
bilder da hat jemand seine sein vater
hubschrauber sozusagen der in eine
sehen wie dort immer wieder anschläge
richtung feuert auf ein ziel das ist
sind wir wissen heute morgen vom
oder seine mutter auf der schulter halb
gouverneur der der region lücke live das
hier ganz anders dieser hubschrauber wir
leblos den körper und bittet hier die
sehen hier feiert also seine raketen
soldaten ihn mitzunehmen
ist hier tote und verletzte gestern
nachgegeben hat warum das ist überhaupt
nach oben er benutzt also quasi seine
wie finde ganz unglaubliche bilder die
nicht klar hier versucht putin aktuell
eigentlich gezielten raketen die er hat
aber nochmal belegen und immer wieder
nicht vorzudringen sondern es scheint so
um boden ziele anzugreifen um irgendwie
zeigen was die ukraine überhaupt denn
dass einfach seine armee immer wieder im
irgendwo etwas ganz weit hinten zu
wir gucken uns mal an wie es dann
mit ihnen mit diesen mehrfach
treffen was er überhaupt nicht sieht und
weitergeht die nächsten aufnahmen zeigen
raketenwerfern mit der artillerie die
der grund dafür ist eben die angst vor
städte einfach die großstädte beschießt
die bereitstehenden ukrainischen
den vom westen gelieferten
um eben terror zu verbreiten um die
evakuierungs busse das ist aus der
flugabwehrgeschützen der der ukrainer
menschen weiterhin auch zuflucht zu
region sagte richer dort wurde
zwingen und alle zivilisten aus dem weg
die russen wissen ganz genau wenn sie
vereinbart gestern diese menschen hin zu
zu kriegen für den fall dass er denn
sich der front nehren dann werden ihre
evakuieren also über mehrere städte
weiter dort vor rücken will
sozusagen herauszubringen aus mario pohl
hubschrauber angegriffen abgeschossen
deshalb diese völlig in effektive taktik
und wir sehen jetzt einfach mal wie
wir gucken uns den osten der ukraine
war sie einen hubschrauber wie ein
viele busse dort warten das sind
jetzt etwas näher an hier haben wir ja
artillerie system ein raketenwerfer zu
hunderte bis man sie zumindest dutzende
verwenden tief zu fliegen zu schießen
busse die hier alle stehen und warten
seit einigen tagen diese grossoffensive
und dann und wir sehen uns mit ganz
auf menschen die eben kommen die aus
russlands die vonstatten geht und wir
vielen flair ist das sind diese ganzen
mario pohl gerettet werden wollen und
wollen uns erst einmal die stadt
kleinen genau diese ganzen kleinen
mariupol ansehen mario pohl
wir wissen mittlerweile dass nur vier
lichter die dort rauskommen das sind
völlig zerstört zu 95 prozent von
leuchtkörper
busse überhaupt genutzt wurden nur vier
eben wegzufliegen falls doch ein
russischen truppen erobert und in mario
busse wurden gestern genutzt von der
ukrainer auf sie schießt mit einer
ukrainischen seite um diese menschen zu
pohl sollte es gestern eine weitere
rakete dass sie nicht getroffen werden
evakuierung geben also wiederum eine
evakuieren
der rest der menschen kam einfach nicht
dass also eine ganz interessante taktik
evakuierung bei der die eingeschlossenen
raus und die frage ist wann kommen die
die im doch zeigt dass die russische
menschen die menschen die eben nicht
menschen und die stadtverwaltung von
luftwaffe großen respekt und große angst
dort weiter leben wollen und die vor
mario pohl sagt seit tagen diese
allem nicht unter russischer kontrolle
vor den flugabwehrgeschützen der ukraine
menschen werden entführt diese menschen
leben wollen eben herausgeholt werden
werden gegen ihren willen in lager nach
hat die eben auf der anderen seite der
aus der stadt und auch gestern hat sich
russland entführt und werden dort
front
wieder einmal mehr gezeigt wie diese
sozusagen auf sie warten wir schauen uns
hingebracht und man weiß nicht was mit
evakuierungen in anführungsstrichen
ihm passiert nach antwort wurde nach
auch nochmal einmal an wie die ukraine
nämlich vonstatten gehen durch die
versucht das ganze hier zu händeln im
aussage der stadtverwaltung wurden
russische armee was wir jetzt sehen sind
osten das sind neue aufnahmen die uns
ungefähr 150.000 menschen bisher aus
wie ich finde schwer zu ertragende
erreicht haben und wie ich finde eine
sehr interessante mischung was wir hier
aufnahmen nicht weil sie blut zeigen
mario pohl nach russland gebracht über
oder verletzungen zeigen sondern weil
sehen ist ein bmw 2 ein ganz neuer
30.000 von denen gegen ihren willen die
sie eben diese demütigung zeigen diese
also nicht evakuiert werden wollten nach
behandlung der ukrainischen
erbeutetes russisches militärfahrzeug
zivilbevölkerung für durch die russische
russland und jetzt dort festgehalten
was jetzt von ukrainern benutzt wird
armee die wie ich finde einfach
werden
darauf eine panzerabwehrwaffe eine
wir schauen uns als nächstes den stand
überhaupt nicht nachvollziehbar ist wir
sozusagen sogenannte entität müsse und
der offensive an und versuchen uns da
sehen ja in russischen soldaten der also
mal zwei aspekte anzusehen die offensive
zivilisten die angeblich sieben wochen
lang im bunker gesessen habe zivilisten
russlands ist hat in der region aktiv in
[Musik]